let me let me just say something really
straight from my heart if I can you know
I lost my dad 32 years ago today April
13th is always tough day for our family
and this morning when my brothers and
sisters were sending around pictures of
dad like we always do I just thought of
the families of them more than 22,000
Americans that we've lost and I just
want to tell you that you're on our
hearts and you're in the prayers of
millions of Americans as you as you deal
with this heartbreaking loss as well as
families that have family members that
are struggling with serious illness but
let me just encourage everyone that in
the midst of that loss because the
American people have been putting these
mitigation measures into practice there
are families that are still together
today and I just want to encourage you
here at roughly the halfway point of 30
days to slow the spread to take take
that to heart
in in no way minimize the losses that
we've experienced as a nation and as
families but but to be encouraged to
know when you see those numbers on the
vast majority of states that because of
what the American people are doing it's
working and dr. Fauci and dr. Burks and
the entire team continually asked us to
remind the American people and we do so
again today keep doing what you're doing
with the 30 days to slow the spread and
we will hasten the day that we heal our
land